Hello, my name is Dr.
Raj, and I'll be talking
about the basic
theoretical principles
of psychotherapy and the
practice of osteopathic
medicine. I am a
clinical psychologist
in the Department of
Family Medicine. My
email address is anu
.raj at nyit.edu. So if
you have any questions
about this lecture,
just email me. I will
emphasize which points
I really want you to
get from this lecture.
Clearly, I want you
at the end of this
session to understand
the major forms of
psychotherapy, its
history, the theoretical
basis, and what are
some of the common
strategies that we
use in our treatment,
and what patient
populations are some of
those treatments the
most advisable for.
Now, why should you
as medical school
students learn about
psychological treatment.
Some of you may be
wondering, well,
why do I have to
attend this lecture?
Well, firstly,
you're in osteopathic
medical school, and we
look at a human being
in a holistic view.
So we talk about
their emotional and
spiritual well-being.
And we talk about
treatments because it's
the education and
knowing the treatment
and knowing the
human in its fullest
form that brings you
closer to your patient
and it makes you an
effective physician,
and also knowing
what some of the
emotional hindrances
may be in a patient's
progress in their
physical well-being
will help you really
tailor their treatment
plans better. So here
are some aspects as
to why you should be
learning these things.
Now, I'm going to
test you on them,
but I want you
to understand
why it's important
that you know and
understand a
person as a whole.
Clearly, you also will
be working in large
teams, and it's really
important for you
to know if somebody
is being noncompliant,
say for smoking
cessation, and you're
working in a cardiology
department or a
pulmonology department,
and you are wondering
why this patient is
having a really hard
time with not smoking
or other substances
like alcohol, you may
want to refer them for
psychological treatment
in those cases.
Again, you want to
have a comprehensive
perspective for the
human being and to
understand their compliance
and to understand
how to set things
up in your treatment
plan so that your
patient is the
most successful
will require you to
understand their
emotional functioning.
And the other part
is that really
our medical school
is trying to
address the stigma
associated with
mental health and
mental illness.
So we really are
encouraging all the
students to understand
and learn all
these aspects of
human functioning.
A few things you should
know, telemedicine
has become really
big since COVID-19.
You'll hear a lot
about ketamine, and
there is in the
reference a listing
of a few articles
and references for
how ketamine is
used for depression.
There are a few
findings, but I will not
focus on it. It's not
my area of expertise.
So if you hear a lot
about it, you should
know that it's not a
universal treatment yet.
And overall, I think
you should, you know,
go look at some of
the references I have
added at the end if
you want to learn more.
So I'll begin
with cognitive
behavioral therapy.
It was developed
by Aaron Beck.
And Aaron Beck really
just focused on negative
thought patterns and
if there are certain
patterns and flavors
in the way people
view their situations
in a negative way.
For example, a person
may have a tendency to
catastrophize. Every
small thing, say you
get an email from a
professor, we need to
talk, and your brain
goes straight to, oh,
it's a catastrophe,
something bad's going
to happen. And if that
tends to be a consistent
pattern, then that
person is always
working from a place
of being defensive and
is really not looking
and prepping for a
meeting like that in a
more effective way. So
there are several
negative thought patterns
that Beck had listed,
and it works as if
you're a statistician.
You look at, well,
how often does your
catastrophizing really
actually have data to
back it? And we ask
patients to keep diaries
and logs of their
thought patterns, and
then we challenge them.
It has been proven
to be consistently
one of the most
effective ways
to address depression
and anxiety
and post-traumatic
stress disorder.
This is something
you should know.
And this is a pattern.
This is how actually
CBT works. So if you
think about a situation
and a human being,
you know, your patient
goes through some
physiological symptoms,
they are hypertensive,
they have heart
palpitations, and the
thought is something
bad is going to happen.
It's terrifying. I
don't control it. And
then there's also a
perception issue of
like people can see me
and then that continues
to feed the negative
self thought that
increases the anxiety.
And then it leads
to, I can't sleep.
I don't think I'll
be able to sleep.
You know, and I don't
think I can cope. I
may be having a heart
attack. By the way,
if somebody is
telling you that, you
should make sure you
rule out heart attack or
some other actual
physical ailment before
you go to a mental
health ailment. And
then when you are
not able to sleep and
you're panicking and
you're not eating well,
you're not taking care
of yourself, you're
more likely to have
more physiological
symptoms. and hence
the cycle continues.
I'm going to
talk also about
mindfulness-based
cognitive therapy.
So mindfulness-based
cognitive therapy is
really about how to
mindfully remain present
without being
judgmental of what's
happening around you and
without being judgmental
of yourself. So
if you are sitting
right now, be mindful
of how you're sitting.
Is your back
leaning forward?
Do you need to
fix your posture?
Do it right now as you're
listening to me.
And I'm doing it
right now as I'm
talking to you.
Is my neck leaning
forward? And you guys
all are taking OMM
classes. You know
what the long-term
impact of all of these
bad posture positions
can have. So
mindfulness-based
cognitive therapy really
talks about where
are your thoughts?
Are they leaning
a certain way?
and if they are just
fix them but there's
no judgment attached
to was that a good
thought or was that a
bad thought whereas in
cognitive behavioral
therapy if you remember
this one with Aaron
Beck um it actually
talks about well
these are negative
thoughts and these you
know some of the thoughts
are positive thoughts
in mindfulness
-based therapies we
don't do any assessment
of whether it was
negative or positive it's
just more of it was
and then what happens
when it is this way.
If I continue to
lean my neck forward,
what will happen to me?
At some point, my
body's going to get
strained, and at some
point, I may either
injure myself or cause
a lot of discomfort,
and it'll carry on
through the rest of my
body, and I'm going
to cause some damage.
And similarly, in our
thoughts, if there's
a thought leaning
one way or the other,
not towards the
middle, then we are
going to injure
ourselves. Now this
actually comes from
Jon Kabat-Zinn.
He went out to East Asia
and studied Buddhism
and Zen Buddhism and
saw how mindfulness
-based practices
really helped people
recover from ailments
quicker than no mindfulness
-based practices.
So he brought it in
to the United States
and introduced it in a
lot of rehab centers
after a lot of surgeries
so he brought in into
orthopedic surgery
departments and he
saw that people were
recovering sooner
after having joint
replacement surgeries
or you know having bone
injuries when they were
also doing mindfulness
based practices
because it removed the
negative judgmental
part of I should have
been recovering
sooner or look at them
recovering and maybe
I'm in a race with them.
So the case example
here, I wanted
you to remember
is that it's about
rumination that
actually interferes
with your ability
to recover.
So see, you know,
cognitive behavioral
therapy and mindfulness
-based cognitive
behavioral therapy
works really well in
preventing relapses.
If somebody's not
doing well and they're
being, you know,
they're getting the
assistance from a
medical team to get
healed, but now they're
busy really judging
themselves and that's
now getting in their
way of healing.
I also use this in
our EDS center with a
lot of patients who
have pain and chronic
pain. And because of
that, they kind of feel
stuck in life and their
progress and goals.
So it really comes in
handy with them in,
well, where are you
right now? Where are
your thoughts leaning?
And is this really
interfering with your
capacity to cope?
Acceptance and
commitment therapy,
ACT, is another newer
type of cognitive
behavioral therapy,
which really
focuses on accepting
where you are.
Again, no judgment.
And this is the part
I think we've done
really well in adopting
from Zen Buddhism.
Accepting where
we are, accepting
the thoughts rather
than aligning
them as good thoughts,
bad thoughts.
constructive thoughts,
destructive thoughts,
and then to really
imagine how you would,
with the thought you
had, move forward. So
an example with an
EDS patient is with
chronic pain, say she is
in a lot of discomfort
and cannot engage in
simple things like
going out to a movie
and dinner can only do
either a movie or a
dinner or cannot go
out to movie or a dinner
on certain days with
bad weather cannot
go out and hold a job
for more than two hours
a day cannot stand
for too long and cannot
start a basic job
where they need to move
around a lot so what
i do with her is to
remind her say you have
a thought about what's
happening in life
and the thought is
about helplessness and
pretend that your brain
your brain has a fog
and I understand that
there's a fog but
because of the fog you
don't stop driving to
your destination you just
need to take a little
longer and you need
to be a little bit
more careful driving
to your destination so
there's absolutely no
judgment on the thought
and there's also
absolutely no getting
frozen in time with the
thought of helplessness.
I do not control the
outcome of my life.
And it's also not
about removing the
fog. It's more of we
will work through the
fog despite the fog.
We will just take
longer to get where
we need to reach.
It's really good for
people with chronic
pain and chronic
levels of depression
where the a sense
of helplessness
and hopelessness
really so strong
that the only thing
they can do in our
sessions is just
come to the session.
I wanted to bring
up anger management
because some of you
may want to work with,
you know, teenagers
and young adults
and teenagers and young
adults tend to need
more anger management.
Adults do too.
But a lot of our
anger management
strategies and
treatments have been very
effective with
teenagers and young
adults. Again, it's
another cognitive
behavioral practice.
And it's really
about controlling
and regulating anger.
So if you think
about, you know, when
somebody comes and
sees, a teenager comes
to see me and has
an anger issue, I
make them keep a log
of what's happening.
And then, you know,
in the log, If
there is an instance,
say, I'll give an
example of a patient
I have right now.
My father does not
want me to go to a
college far away. My
father and my mother both
want me to stay
nearby on Long Island.
And I was really
angry, so I went
up and, you know,
slammed the doors.
And I'm busy
slamming the doors
practically
every day, every
interaction I have
with my parents.
So what I do is I've
made the teenager
sit and write. what
was the instance in
which you felt so
angry that you had
to slam a door or
you had to act it out
in some level of
expression of anger,
whether it's property
destruction, because
if you slam the
doors enough times,
at some point, you
may break something,
punch a wall,
throw something,
or stomp your
feet, all really
extreme expressions
of anger.
What was the thought?
And the thought usually
has to do with i do
not control the outcome
um so i then bring
in some relaxation
techniques on how to
really regulate your body
so that you don't the
body doesn't go into
um fight or flight
mode where where the
teenager's not feeling
cornered and then also
work on the thought
patterns of i am feeling
hopeless or helpless
or cornered and
instead of that to
restructure the thought of.
They are telling
me something I do
not like, so now
I need to think
about what they're
saying, and I
understand that
they don't like it.
They don't like
what I'm saying,
and I don't like
what they're
saying, but I need
to find an effective
way to communicate
with them.
So there's a lot
of pausing in
anger management,
and it's mixed
with relaxation
training. Okay.
The research study
here that I'm talking
about is listed
in the references.
EMDR is an eye movement
desensitization
reprocessing type
of treatment. It's
very specific for
people with PTSD.
And the logic is that
for people with PTSD,
they're hyper *******
when they are in a
situation that reminds
them of the traumatic
situation. So let's
take a war veteran, for
example, or somebody
who survived fires.
We're having fires in
California right now.
And it could be
a stimuli, an
olfactory stimuli,
burning, right?
Burning in war or
burning in wildfires. and
that triggers a response
and that triggers
an anxious response
and the person has um
wants to flee it's
either i'm gonna fly away
or i'm gonna fight and
and they're so *******
that they will either
attack whoever's
in front of them trying
to have a reasonable
conversation with them
or they will flee.
EMDR actually has the
person patient sit in
a session where
they're asked to recall
certain instances and
images of the traumatic
event. And the therapist
then during the
trigger will actually
do something at the edge
of the peripheral view
field of the patient
and it could be
something like this which
is I'm just snapping
my fingers right it is
to change the brain
chemistry associated with
that particular
traumatic memory you do
not send your patients
for EMDR to just anyone
you really want if your
patient is traumatized
to send them to
somebody who really is
fully trained in EMDR
and has been doing
this for a long time
because the worst thing
you want is to send
your patient to a half
-baked somebody who
comes and says oh I know
EMDR that's very different
than I am certified
in EMDR because the
worst thing is for
your patient to sit in
a session and relive
the traumatic memories
and the events and have
the sensation of
being back there where
their entire entity and
in existence was being
questioned and not
have an effective,
qualified practitioner
in their room with them.
So I usually
refer anybody
who's in need
for EMDR out.
And I would suggest
that if somebody
needs something
like that with you,
really think
about looking for
somebody who's
certified, okay?
Cognitive processing
therapy is very similar
to EMDR. It's that
you actually trigger
the traumatic events
by writing about them.
And as you write about
them, A, you're no
longer holding on
to the thoughts and
feelings associated with
the traumatic event.
And after you
write them, you
read them with
your clinician.
and the clinician helps
you restructure it
in a way where you no
longer feel that you
are out of control or
you don't have a say in
the outcome of the
event, right? So if you
think about a domestic
violence victim who
is in a situation where
they have no control
over the outcome of
what's happening and
they are asked to sit
down and write about
their traumatic memories,
a clinician will
sit with them and explain
how writing it down
gives them a sense of
control because then
they own the experience,
but then also can
compare their current
state with what happened
in the traumatic
state and learn to
differentiate between
the past and the present.
Dialectical behavioral
therapy dbt is
something you'll hear a
lot about um and if any
of you have watched
lifetime movies a lot
of the characters
um have borderline
personality disorders
or or borderline ish
um dbt was developed by
marshall anahan in the
80s who also went out
to asia to learn
about zen buddhism and
she combined zen
buddhism with cognitive
behavioral therapy the
reason being is that
if you think about what
it what a human being
exhibits to be diagnosed
with borderline
personality disorders
are you know
parasuicidal or pseudo
suicidal behavior um a lot
of cutting um a lot
of threats to hurt
themselves um and there
is a certain level of
manipulation involved
in there that you
know if you don't do
this i will run away um
that kind of
manipulation is involved
usually involves other
people around them and
somebody with borderline
personality disorder
is not necessarily
born with it um
similar to other
pathologies in mental health
borderline personality
disorder also is a
product of an interplay
of genetics an
environment. So if
they've been raised in an
environment where
they are mistreated
consistently but then
are told it's out of love
and they have nobody
else in their life
and experiences to
correct that for them,
they may exhibit some
BPD type of behavior.
So the CBT part of
dialectical behavioral
therapy is the emotional
regulation, the
interpersonal effectiveness
in that. In your
interactions, they're
expected to keep journals
as well. Pretty much
in all of ABA and CBT,
you will see that we
ask patients to keep
journals because we want
them to have ownership
for their behavior
and also ownership of
their own treatment and
to track it and also
give them the toolkits,
the tools that
they need in their
toolkit that they
can always go back
and refer to even if
they're no longer
seeing the clinician.
So some of the CBT
techniques are about
interpersonal effectiveness.
And so an example
of that is, well, if
you were interacting
with your boyfriend
and you wanted your
boyfriend to stay
with you, threatening
something being
disastrous if they didn't
stay with you is
manipulative and it's
probably not a really
good interpersonal
interaction in the
long run for a stronger
bond. The emotional
regulation part is what
happened in your
conversation with your
boyfriend for you to
feel that you needed
to go and suggest such
an extreme measure.
The mindfulness part is
the Zen Buddhism part
and the mindfulness
is did you realize you
were doing this did
you realize that when
you've done this in
the past you've had a
track record of doing
this in the past and
in the past when this
happens the outcome
is if you threaten
personal damage you end
up in the er now i
want you guys to also
know one thing if
you're going to have
somebody with borderline
personality disorder
and they have a
tendency to threaten
with parasuicidal
suicidal behavior
you don't ever dismiss
it because somebody
in their family or
friend circle is
saying, yeah, they do
this every few weeks
or so. No, they go
to the ER because
that is the consequence
of making a threat
like this. And you
don't know which threat
is real and which
one's manipulative,
right? So you can
never read a patient's
mind. You want to
listen to the words.
And if the words
are, I intend to
cause harm myself
or to someone else,
that is a threat,
regardless of
what you think
the intention may
be. All right.
So remember that.
In DBT,
again, another thing
to remember is if you
are going to be
referring somebody with
borderline personality
issues and somebody
around you says in your
team, oh, I know DBT.
Again, refrain from
referring your patient
to that person. Somebody
who's trained in
DBT will very proudly
tell you that they're
certified in DBT and
that DBT on its own
has its own support
network for clinicians.
So a clinician who's
doing DBT, because
it is such a draining
type of treatment
modality, that
it requires the
clinician to have
their own support team.
So when I got trained
for DBT, I did not
want to be certified in
it because that would
require me to belong
to a larger DBT team.
It required me
to be on call 24
hours, and I had
little babies at
that time, so I
didn't want that.
But remember that
you're looking for
people who are fully
trained in these
treatment modalities
when you're
referring your
patients to them, okay?
Okay, what DBT also
does is that it follows
sort of like Maslow's
hierarchy in what's
the topmost tier for
a human existence is
to make sure you're
existing first. So they're
going to first,
in the first tier,
address any kind of
suicidal, parasuicidal,
pseudosuicidal behavior
and threat. And then
the second part will
be we really want to
make sure we address
adherence to treatment.
If they're not coming
to treatment, then
they're not going to
benefit. So if somebody's
consistently five
minutes late or if
somebody consistently
forgets their journal,
clearly there is an
underlying thought
process of their
treatment and adherence
to treatment that
can be questioned.
So DBT also
addresses these kinds
of commitment to
treatment behavior.
And DBT also requires
the patient to be in
individual therapy and
group therapy because
it's important for
them to learn from
lessons of their peers on
how they have progressed
in emotional regulation
or how much they
struggled with
dysregulation in the past.
Applied behavior
analysis.
This is an important
part. so pay attention,
because this gets
used a lot in our
daily lives, right?
So it's basically
a reward-punishment
cycle, and
a lot of our
society's structures
and policies are
based on ABA.
If you remember,
B.F. Skinner,
with his pigeons,
came up with the
concept of operant
conditioning.
It's basically all
desired behaviors have
a consequence that
is desirable, and all
undesirable behaviors
have a consequence that
is undesirable. So it's
the reward punishment
kind of schedule,
right? So positive
reinforcement is when
you're adding something
to the treatment plan
that is positive and
desirable when the
patient is behaving in a
positive and desirable
way. And so there's
a lot of shaping and
chaining involved. So
what does it mean for
shaping and chaining?
Shaping is
basically if, say,
somebody is having a
really hard time with
a certain behavior and
we want them to shape
it so that they're
able to do the full
behavior. So you start
shaping parts of the
behavior. So ABA gets
used a lot with children
with autism and say
an example is there's
a boy who can't sit
still okay so the shaping
will be that you
first teach the boy to
be able to sit still
for two minutes barring
of course any physical
reasons that the
boy can't sit still
and if the boy can sit
still for like two
minutes then you you know
give them a reward and
and usually the reward
at a younger age is
the primary reinforcer
which is food but
after a certain age we
move away from food
because relying just on
food is a really bad
way to continue doing
reinforcement schedules
for older children
because they begin
associating food as
reward or punishment and
then that's a disaster
story for eating
disorders later on.
But for a three or
four-year-old, three or
four-year-old child
on spectrum and she's
walking down the hall,
and what you really want
is for her to shape
her behavior to be able
to walk down the hall,
right, to get to her
preschool class, is
shaping even, you know,
where are her hands?
If she's flapping
her hands, if
she's able to keep
her hands down,
and there will be
physical prompt at
that age in ABA.
And these are ABA
trained. I was also ABA
trained. We are trained
in how to do it without
causing harm to a
child. And so there's a
physical prompt. And
as soon as the child
can do the physical prompt
for a certain amount
of time, and the
duration can literally
be just five seconds or
10 seconds, there's a
primary enforcer. It
could be like their
favorite snack or favorite
chip or favorite M
&M. And that's, by the
way, where the M&M
references ever come
up if you hear them in
psychology context and
we say where's the M&Ms
it's got it's related to
ABA and shaping behavior.
Chaining is if I got
the this young four-year
-old young lady to
walk down the hall now
how do I get her to
do other things so now
she's had the positive
outcome so far if she
can walk 10 you know
seconds for 10 seconds
down the hall and
she's sitting down she
had to walk say you know
20 yards she's sitting
down now how do i get
her to sit and just
sit still in a group
and that's chaining
good so you chain it
by adding duration like
every five minutes
i'm gonna add a reward
every five minutes i'm
gonna add a reward um
and then move her
baseline up that way
i did that in my in
in the social skills
training of children
on the spectrum.
So there are a lot
of nuances that goes
into getting a group
of four to five kids
who are on the spectrum
together because
some of them may
engage in visual
hyperstimulation by
flapping their hands on the
edges or jumping up
and down or covering
their eyes and
uncovering their eyes or
making some kind of
noise because they
want that kind of
stimulation or that they're
overly stimulated
by the environment.
So even getting five
to, you know, four
to five kids like this
in one room to sit
and actually have
a group requires a
lot of background work
by the commission.
So if you look
at the chart on
the left side,
you know, positive
reinforcement
is basically,
by the way, everyone
will have a taste of
it when you guys get
employed. You also have
a taste, somewhat
of a taste of it now
but when you're employed
you show up to work
you do your work you
deliver on time you're
professional and
courteous and the positive
reinforcement is you
get a salary right
whereas a punishment
is you don't show
up to work you don't
do your work you're not
collegial and the
negative is you don't
get your salary or
worse you lose your work
An extinction schedule
is when somebody's
doing an undesirable
behavior so much so
that it requires a
separate treatment plan.
And so we call
that an extinction
schedule, which
is basically we
want that behavior
to go extinct.
So if you think about I
want a kid's, a really
classic example is a two
-year-old interrupting
their parent. Now,
if any of you have
been around a two-year
-old, the best way to
teach a two-year-old to
continue to interrupt
a parent is as soon
as the two-year-old
taps on the parent's
elbow, arm, whatever, and
the parent turns around
and says, stop it.
And the kid goes,
tap, tap, tap, tap.
And the parent goes,
stop it. If you
think about the
reinforcement schedule
we're talking
about, the kid is
getting attention,
and that's their
reinforcement for
inappropriate behavior.
so what the parent
should be doing is
putting that on an
extinction schedule which
is the kid goes tap
tap tap tap tap and
the parent does not
respond the kid continues
to go tap tap tap
tap tap tap and the
parent continues to
ignore the child and
the kid goes tap
tap tap tap and you
continue to ignore and
that is an extinction
schedule all right so
the reason I wanted
to bring this up by
the way in the ABA
is that if when you're
working with children
and teenagers you'll
hear about star
charts and behavior
charts this is all
based on BF Skinner's
operant conditioning
okay now let's talk
about systematic
desensitization it kind
of works in a combination
of operant conditioning
and relaxation so
Wolpe came up with this
model and it's really
terrific and fantastic
for phobias. Just
think about like
specific phobias. So say
somebody has a
phobia for a flying,
which a few of my
current patients
do, and I'll give
you an example.
So systematic
desensitization talks about
desensitizing the
person to a stimuli,
but in a very
systematic way to allow
them to give them
control over the outcome
of that particular
session, right? So
say somebody is really
afraid of flying
and they can't stand
being in an airport.
They can't stand
getting close to an
airport. So what I do
is we start with A,
giving them some
control over the
physiological symptoms.
So there is systematic
desensitization in that I
teach them
relaxation skills.
If you can have
biofeedback, that's great
because then they can
see on the computer
that their brain
waves are calmer when
they do certain
types of relaxation
exercises. So they do
a relaxation exercise.
And then I up the
ante very gradually
in order to
expose them to the
stimuli that
they're afraid of.
So exercise, have control
over your breathing,
have control over
your heart rate,
control over your heart
palpitations, control
over the negative
thoughts about flying
and the fear of flying
and then after a few
weeks of control on
that drive by the
airport and as you're
driving by the airport
continue the exercise
continue the deep
breathing continue the
physiological control
now the systematic
desensitization requires
you to like step up
the ladder the next
progressive step is get
into the airport just
go sit and so go sit
in the airport do
nothing come back then
eventually which they
we can no longer do but
i have found a way to
uh to simulate sitting
on a plane um by
sending them to certain
museums where i say
okay these museums have
flight chairs you need
to sit down and pretend
you're on a flight
or to go to a planetarium
um where you can
have a 40 experience
where your chairs also
kind of move as the
filming that you're
watching in the planetarium
also kind of moves.
And that gives you
a simulation of
like being on a
plane for just a
few minutes. And
then they continue
to practice
relaxing their body.
That seems to be the
most effective and
kind way to work with
specific phobias.
Another way is the
case example is like a
patient is phobic of
dogs how do you get them
to you know the other
way is know that your
body wants to come
back to rest no matter
what right so if we know
that our body wants to
come back to equilibrium
you can just throw
them in a pen with
all the dogs of course
the dogs are not the
kind who would bite them
but the dogs are just
walking around and so
the person's going to
have a panic attack
in the midst of the
dogs and eventually the
body will want to come
back to equilibrium.
So they will eventually
find that their body
goes back to rest. Now
that's a really unpleasant
experience. And then
you may also trigger
some cardiac event
if the person's not
very physically
healthy. So systematic
desensitization is a
preferred method for phobias.
Now let's talk about
psychoanalysis.
Of course, it came
up, it was brought
up by Sigmund
Freud, who was a
neurologist by
training, and he worked
with upper-class
women in pre-World
War I and pre-World
War II Austria.
And he used to talk
about free association
and dream analysis
and transference.
So free association is
what you classically
see in TV, which is
you lie down on a
couch and just keep
talking about whatever
comes to mind and
therapist says very little
and the therapist
sits there
with you know
their notepad just
you know taking
notes that's it
the role of the
therapist is to just
see the patterns in
the free association
but they say very little
and that as you're
going through the
free association the
expectation is that
you will self-actualize
the patterns the
second part that freud
talked about was dream
analysis he actually
wrote a book with
brewer on dream analysis
which is fantastic
if you guys ever
want to have time at
3 a.m to read it and
transference this is
something we still use
a lot in psychological
treatment transference
is a patient comes
in to see you and
that can happen And not
just with psychology,
it can happen with
anyone. So it can
happen and it will
happen with you guys.
Patient comes in
and you in some
way, shape or
form, remind them
of somebody else
in their life.
It could be your
stature. It could
be a fragrance
in the hallway.
It could be the
lighting in the hallway.
These are all
subconscious memories
that get triggered.
So they see you and
they're reminded
of somebody else in
their life. and
they start treating
you as if you are
that somebody else.
That's transference.
Countertransference
is if you
start treating
the patient
in a way that's
different than you would
other patients because
they are reminding you
of somebody from your
life. So say it's an
elderly person who's
walking in and they're
bringing you a bunch
of cookies and they're
saying, oh, how can
you be a doctor? You're
such a little, you're
so young, you look
so cute. you remind
me of my grandchild um
and they're baking
and buying you cookies
and everything that's
transference now you
can use that kind of
positive transference
um in your treatment but
you have to be careful
because you know they
could also be doing
something inappropriate
with transference
which is acting out where
you may be reminding
them of a previous
relationship where
they were truly hurt or
traumatized or injured
so you want to be
careful of not feeding
too much into it and
encounter transference
is when you're
treating a patient like
they're your grandparent
um and when in reality
they're sitting there
going i'm just john
smith sitting here
talking to you about
what's happening with
me in my life all right
so the best way to
deal with transference
and counter-transference
for yourself is to
make sure you're aware
of your blind spots
um so of course in
freudian analysis
the you know freud
talks about the
unconscious mind
so So if you think
of an iceberg, what's
under the water
and unseen is the
unconscious mind.
What is above on
the iceberg is the
conscious mind. So
a very small tip
of the iceberg is
visible, right?
And he talked about
****** stages of
development. He talked
about defense mechanisms,
which I will refer
to in a minute.
And how you can
use those defense
mechanisms in
psychiatry. So denial
is one we all
know about, right?
i don't want to deal
with reality it's
too difficult for me
to deal with reality
for whatever reason
it may be disruptive
right repression is i'm
i just don't remember
it the way you
remember it um and the
projection is i'm stressed
out so i'm going to
call you stressed out
so if it's ever happened
to you going you
look really tired but
you're thinking i
really am not but maybe
you're tired so you have
to be careful not to
say that out loud
but in your mind like
that projection that
kind of projection may
also happen you know
um and displacement is
i'm going to take my
feelings and have an
outlet so we'll talk
about some of the outlets
that people also have
and sublimation is
just i just cannot do
this so i will adopt
unacceptable or or
impulsive behaviors so
what are some of the
mature mechanisms right
mature ways to deal
with distress um
altruism clearly you
know it's you are when
somebody gets really
into giving giving giving
because they want they
they don't want to
pause and focus on
their own self right um
humor you know if you
want to express your
discomfort by making
a joke about it right
right um and you want
to um take something
that you're having a
difficulty with um and
reroute it as well I'm
going to take it out
in this way like I will
show up five minutes
late to a meeting all
the time um and of
course there are these
like lesser mature
mechanisms of like
acting out I can't take
this so i'm going to
act out or i'm going
to you know behave in
a way that's negative
um i have listed
the examples here
for you to look
at later on um
dissociation is
definitely one of them
that shows up um
again in pop culture a
lot but um for dissociation
for it to really
truly be a dissociation
it would have
to be associated of
something extremely
traumatic um and
usually in childhood um
where emotions were
more prevalent than
language was if you
don't have enough
language skills which
we don't as children
we process the
world through
emotions and if
something really
terrible happens
to us then
then those adults tend to
dissociate um
when they grow up
All right. Humanistic
therapy. I'm going
to just quickly go
over this. Carl Rogers
brought this up.
So if you've heard
of like Rogerian
psychology, it's about
really focusing on
the person and their
own personal growth
and self-actualization
and focusing on that
person as to what
it is in their self
-esteem that's keeping
them from being
their fullest self.
Interpersonal therapy
is really about
social relationships,
how to make sure that
you're communicating
in an effective way,
how best to address
what's happening in
your depression when
you're trying to
communicate, and how to
change the communication
style so that you're
lesser depressed.
short-term psychodynamic
treatment really
is not the lying down
on the couch freudian
three times a week
type of therapy but
more of we're going to
talk about transference
counter-transference
your subconscious
processes but we're
not going to do it
three times a week we're
going to have we're
going to talk about
um i am if i am your
therapist i'm not going
to sit quietly and
just take notes i'm
going to tell you did
you see this pattern
did you notice that
this is the the outcome
when you do this.
Group therapy
talks about finding
group themes,
finding support
and learning from
each other. So it
really works well
with social anxiety
because you get to
sit and practice
interacting with other
people, but with other
people with similar
types of fears
of socially engaging
in conversations.
And people who also
struggle with substance
*****, if you think
about AA is a really
good example of group
therapy and also very
effective for substance
***** and chronic other
kind of chronic illnesses
when people talk
about group therapy
for chronic illnesses
it is really great
even if the participant
your patient doesn't
want to say anything
to just sit and listen
to other people because
they may be tapping
into some of the
experiences your patient
is going through um
couples therapy again
um started unfortunately
in the eugenics
movement but um was then
again readdressed in
the 50s and 60s and it
talks about romantic
relationships and resolving
interpersonal conflict
and how in the
marriage the duo instead
of dueling with each
other needs to duel the
issue at hand similar
in family therapy
it could be that in
family therapy the
interesting thing is it's
usually one identified
patient and that one
identified patient is
central in the family's
dysfunction they may
not be contributing
to the dysfunction
but a lot of family's
dysfunction circulates
around that so when that
identified patient tries
to improve themselves
the family will place
structures on them
where the person can't
improve so you really
if you are seeing
those kind of dynamics
in your office you want
to find a qualified
family therapist for
that family and these
are my references all
right I am I'm done.